welcome welcome in to Market takes look
first of all a Happy nuggets 2023 NBA
championship day to those of you who
celebrate out there I know I'm
celebrating Denver Nuggets 2023 NBA
champs but of course that's about
yesterday and today we are looking into
the CPI Consumer Price Index reports
here on Market takes I am Dion Robert
Bowen reporter at the Wall Street
Journal we are going to dive into this
data but don't forget Denver Nuggets are
2023 NBA champions uh listen this
morning CPI report was a big one
um it's got a lot of folks in the
markets excited especially on the risk
asset side we are going to break down
what it means what the data said what
this tells us going forward we're going
to talk about what the report showed how
it compared to expectations of course
how this sets up the Federal Reserve
because as we know everything moves the
way the FED moves we're going to take a
look at those markets tell you about how
they're responding talk about the
biggest takeaways from this report and
what comes next so first of all let's
throw up here on your screen in this
chart showing what's going on with CPI
now as you see there we have seen 11
straight months of decline in the year
over year consumer price index that
means inflation has been slowing every
single month since we hit that peak of
nine percent in June that's that big
tall bar you see there over in your
screen about the middle of 2022 ever
since then we've seen inflation
consistently come down and then today we
got a four percent reading inflation
Rising four percent year over year well
below that nine percent number and Below
those five percent and 4.9 percent that
we've had the past couple months so
again that acceleration and declining or
the acceleration or decelerating uh
inflation rate continues that supposed
to risk bullish for risk assets we want
to throw another chart up here on your
screen now this is core Consumer Price
Index that's not quite as bullish as you
see they're holding up above five
percent the reading for this month was
5.3 percent so core inflation hasn't
been coming down in that same nice way
wave pattern that we saw for overall CPI
you're seeing the core CPI really a
little bit more stubborn holding up a
little bit higher and that just
illustrating that some pieces of this
inflation story are not moving the way
the Federal Reserve would like them to
so this is something that's why markets
I think we're very excited when this
data first came out four percent uh
right on the numbers right in line with
expectations the month over month change
was just 0.1 percent this was an
exciting exciting report for the market
but then you saw oh wait hold on let's
look at that core number and you started
to see a little bit of change in the
market so that's what we're seeing right
now overall there were some worries as
we came into this report we had seen new
home sales jump last month to the
highest since March 2022 we had seen
purchasing managers indexes showing uh
business activity starting to rebound uh
the highest in a number of months we'd
seen Services be a major concern for the
FED retail sales last month unexpectedly
picked up so there were all things to
suggest that consumers were still going
going out spending that maybe inflation
could be higher but as we saw in the
report today four percent year over year
Well down continuing a string of
declining lower CPI numbers and and CPI
increases or increases in inflation what
were the biggest contributors to this
report well we saw shelter gas and used
cars being the biggest things holding
the biggest things moving inflation
higher now those all matter because one
what do we know about shelter shelter
has been consistently coming down
according to real-time measures of the
economy but we know that CPI shelter
gets fed in on a lag so even though the
shelter index is rising consistently
that's based on older data the real-time
data tells us that shelter costs are
coming down what do we know about gas we
know gas is very volatile it moves up
and down significantly so when you get a
big spike up in gas or a big move down
in gas gas actually moved down
significantly but we know that that is
not one of the major pieces that the
Federal Reserve looks at because it's
not something they can really control
that's more controlled by OPEC Global
oil demand things like that that's not
something the FED can really attack or
bring down and what's that other piece
used cars well that's goods and we know
that Goods prices have been well below
overall inflation coming down much
faster than the overall pace of
inflation so when they picked up this
month well that's going against the
trend and that suggests that maybe
that's not something to be that worried
about so all the things that really
would need to be moving in the right
direction are in these things that are
moving in the wrong direction namely
used cars and shelter real-time measures
of the economy tells us that those
aren't really things that we need to be
worried about and those are things that
in terms of the overall trend are moving
in favor of inflation coming back down
so big picture inflation continues to
cool continues to come down but it's
being held up by a couple things that
could go away you don't really know
they're not things the Federal Reserve
controls but you also have to look at
that core inflation and say okay well
that's mostly being held up by Goods but
it's staying around the same level it's
not coming down the way we'd want it to
um Ronald Temple he's the chief Market
strategist at Lazard he's an investor
there Chief Market strategist he had an
interesting quote I want to read it to
you really quickly he said quote another
month of course CPI over 40 basis points
is disturbing on the surface but Used
Cars and auto insurance drove nearly
half the increase this month
more importantly shelter inflation
remained at a substantially lower level
than recent Peak levels and will
continue to decelerate while other
services inflation was contained overall
the FED should feel comp should feel
comfortable with the pause at tomorrow's
meeting and its tightening appears to be
working on the stickiest drivers of
inflation so that is good news because
we don't we know investors don't want
the FED to keep tightening rates don't
want the FED to keep raising rates
higher making it more difficult for
businesses to go out and borrow money
more expensive to borrow money making
those credit card rates rise higher
making those personal loan rates rise
higher those home equity lines of credit
and home equity loans rise higher get
more expensive those things all slow
down the economy make people less likely
to spend the market doesn't want that
the market wants folks spending that
money and and going out there and doing
those things speaking of let's check in
on the market right now I want to put up
here on your screen the the latest data
that we're seeing what we're seeing from
the market now you saw the Dow after the
report came out just really take off
like a rocket ship we are seeing a bit
of moderation you're seeing the S P 500
kind of coming down a little bit and the
NASDAQ you see not quite as much
exuberance as what we're seeing there
from the Dow but all up about half a
percent on the day I think the really
interesting response to this is in the
bond market there what you're seeing on
your screen here this data is the
10-year yield that's the most traded
Treasury and you're seeing it just take
off and Spike up higher going up to 3.85
about five basis points a day but that
is a big move for the 10-year note
you're seeing the same thing on the
seven year note look at this these long
dated bonds you're seeing just a big
pick up and takeoff now when we go to
short dated bonds you're seeing just the
opposite you're seeing those numbers
come down the two-year uh spiking back
up but you see the one year the six
month the three month all those bonds
that are really correlated to what the
Federal Reserve is going to do and
what's going to happen right now in the
near-term future those are coming way
down investors saying we want to buy
bonds we think yields are coming down
and inflation coming down in the short
term but when you look at this 10-year
number that big spike that suggests that
maybe the Federal Reserve not doing as
much has got investors a little spooked
about what that could mean for the
future of inflation and what that can
mean for inflation longer term so that's
definitely something you want to watch
out for we look over here at currencies
you're seeing the Euro up a little bit
really it took off after that CPR data
was released and you see here a big
spike higher but it's kind of come back
down after that really currencies not
seeing a big move after this I think the
move here in crypto is interesting
because you're still seeing Bitcoin
again right after that report was
released Bitcoin took off but it's
coming back down a lot of that bullish
enthusiasm that was in markets has come
off now and we're seeing markets kind of
come down so really those numbers just
illustrating the overall Market reaction
markets really getting bullish and
excited after that report came out four
percent oh down right on the numbers but
you know what uh when we look at that
core number when we really dig into the
report maybe there's not as much to be
excited about and also as we know stocks
and risky assets have really rallied
over the past week or so maybe you know
this is a bit of uh buy the rumor sell
the news well we got the news CPI came
in as expected and markets are saying
all right maybe it's not that much to be
excited about but let's break down what
we can expect after this report from the
Federal Reserve so the Federal Reserve
widely expected to pause as in the fed's
been raising rates ever since March 2022
the expectation coming into this meeting
before we got this data or any other or
a lot of data for this week was that
they were going to say hey let's take a
let's take a step back let's breathe
let's see the effect of what we've
already done before we go about raising
rates anymore well this report with
inflation CPI inflation coming in at
four percent really backs the case that
definitely pauses the right move and
maybe going forward we don't need to
raise rates anymore maybe going forward
we can just you know back off and and
maybe even start cutting rates which is
what the market really wants and Market
has been pricing in so initially very
bullish for risk assets but that core
number again putting a bit of a pin in
that uh the FED expected to hold rates
according to Fed funds Futures at this
June meeting but then expected to raise
rates in July and interestingly I
thought with this kind of bullish CPI
number you would see the expectations
for that July rate increase to really
come all all the way off but you're not
seeing that investors still expecting
the FED to raise rates next month which
I think is very interesting so a lot is
going to hinge on what we hear from Fed
chair Jerome Powell at this meeting A
lot's going to hinge on what we see from
the summary of economic projections that
we get from the fed and you know this is
again the FED is still expected to raise
rates next month about 60 percent chance
priced into fed fund's Futures markets
so investors saying okay the CPI report
says that you pause in June but then you
still raise in July and then what is
that set up for the rest of the year and
we're gonna have to get clarification on
that from the fed and we're really not
going to know so I think tomorrow's fed
meeting is obviously going to be highly
watched it's going to be very important
what we hear the chairman say and what
we see from the other fed members in
terms of how they're viewing the markets
and I think that could potentially start
setting us up for a very big Blockbuster
July report depending on how this other
data comes in what the FED says will be
very important in terms of how the
market reads and what we can expect to
see from the market going through for
the rest of this year so the biggest
takeaway from this report again we see
inflation continuing to come down you
see that four percent number well below
more than half uh or less than half of
what it was in June and about halfway to
the fed's two percent Target again the
fed's target is two percent inflation uh
and we're about halfway there more than
halfway there because we were at nine
percent back in June of 2022. so as we
sit here in June of 2023 as the FED has
already started their meeting they've
kicked it off and they're talking about
this report right now just like I'm
talking to you guys about it right here
they're saying okay what does this mean
for us and they're looking at that core
CPI number they're looking at that
overall CPI number they're looking at
the month over month change and they're
saying the folks who were in the camp of
we need to pause they are probably you
know feeling really good about their
position right now folks who said no we
need to keep raising rates who would
come out and and really actively
campaign for that they're probably kind
of okay well maybe I'll be quiet right
now because quiet but we'll see how the
rest of the data comes out so again
tomorrow's retail sales report is also
going to be very important and you're
going to want to or sorry not tomorrow
Thursday's retail sales report is going
to be important but we know that the big
Market mover is going to be tomorrow the
Federal Reserve report the statement
comes out at 2 pm then we hear from the
chairman at 2 30. we will be right here
on Market takes at 4 after the market
closes to tell you all about what
happened at that fed meeting what the
chairman said break down what he said
what he didn't say what was in the
statement and why it matters so we'll be
doing that all here tomorrow at four
o'clock I hope you'll join us we also
like I said get retail sales on Thursday
and then next week's housing data I
think is going to be very big again as
this shelter component has continued to
hold up inflation if we can start to see
continued deceleration and declines in
some of these existing home sales
numbers if new if new home sales start
to pull back again and move lower that
could really be bullish for the markets
and again I think this Market could have
legs because the data is starting to
support a lot of this bullishness and
enthusiasm that's in the markets that's
already been priced into stock prices so
you know we could see that next week is
Juneteenth uh Happy Juneteenth we are
going to be out on Monday but we'll be
back here on Tuesday to give you that
report so stick with us on Market takes
man we will be coming to you with all
the information that you need uh that's
going to about wrap it up for us but
again tomorrow four o'clock P.M we will
be breaking down that fed meeting right
here hope you'll join us listen I'm Dion
rabone reporter for the Wall Street
Journal that's it for this edition of
Market takes I hope that you will be
with us next time